it and this is just genuine question
should a woman if you tell her something
and it's not something that she agrees
with how should she go about it because
at some point there's going to be
something that you tell her that she
disagrees with last being an example
otherwise because there's so many
different things that would be so
um
oh you got one I have one so you and
this is something common that I've
like older Generations you want to buy a
house
she thinks you're being too Reckless
with the money
she gets absolutely zero so zero so zero
say when the man has earned all that
money and she is it depends on the
dynamic if the man is the only one
working and providing then he she gets
absolutely zero so because it's the
man's money and he's providing you a
house you it's like Beggars can't be
choosers right I know that's the wrong
technology most girls have to work in
2022. I don't know I'm talking about
Dynamic where the man don't where the
woman doesn't work obviously if the
woman 2022 so most girls have to work
like she has to help pay the mortgage my
my opinion no I don't really have an
opinion I'm just trying to figure out
okay so in that case I wouldn't I
wouldn't like be happy with that at all
but if someone was in a situation where
the woman was also earning and she was
also contributing then definitely
however much I believe it should be very
static so however much he contributes is
how much say she has so if the man earns
70 and she earns 30 I believe she should
have a 30 Say by that logic if a girl
earns more than a guy she should have
the final say yes but I also don't agree
with the woman working if it wants to be
a dynamic of the man and woman in a
masculine feminine okay well yeah I mean
that's the ideal yeah I think most girls
would like to be Housewives but again
we're in 2022. I think lower the
standards I think living standards okay
go ahead the key thing is yeah you're
saying we're 20 22 going into 2023. we
can't be we've got to always look at it
and I think just looking at like the no
tests
feel like genuine like generally
if the female has the respect levels
that she should have for you and she's
going for the type of man
that she a genuine King then the testing
is not really going to happen and going
on to that the the split so talking
about like the property with things
if if the female's earning of course it
makes sense to communicate on on the
twist to say that ah do you know what
I'm gonna make a choice you're gonna
have problems in 10 years and she's just
gonna bottle things up you're asking for
a problem it's about genuinely you have
to
communicate well with each other hear
each other's voice
and because it's different now what
percentage when the man's earning all of
the money is is it's not really
happening like that females generally
are working they're earning money
they're doing projects however she can
be earning the same amount but if she
really has trust in you she's going to
let you naturally lead with a decision
the problem is there's a lot of men
earning the same or a little bit less
than the female of course the female's
not going to trust the man because a lot
of these a lot of these males out here I
don't even trust them myself so like
they can't they can't manage their own
money during that Dynamic the woman
actually has more so because that woman
normally is in control of the sex in the
marriage and if the man doesn't do what
she wants she's gonna it's gonna become
a secless marriage but then she's the
she's the masculine one yeah that's what
happened yeah she deserves that I can't
I can't speak yeah that's why I
personally wouldn't want someone who's
working I would want my wife to be a
full-on stay-at-home wife so and that's
how I avoid that that situation that you
just brought up uh what if she's working
and then she wants to contribute and
then she gets to say in my opinion it
should be the man's the only one dealing
with the money and financial side it's
just it's just like nowadays it's
idealistic you know what I think the
whole idea of there being no test sounds
great but the purpose of a test is to
prove how competent someone is so if
she's constantly testing you she's
trying to show how competent you are and
let's be honest you can never you can
never get too comfortable so I think
passive testing is good but I don't
think direct testing is good at all yeah
I think I think it's intent like what's
your intent is it to make your man feel
small or is it to be like okay how is
this leadership because I mean I I'm a
self-aware woman I don't again I don't
know a single wife that wasn't that
doesn't test her man but mine is the
only the only ish test that I have left
that I even do and it I think at this
point in time I like I think it might
just be out of habit but the one thing
I'll do is like I'll be thinking in my
head I'm like ah I want a glass of water
but I don't want to get out of bed I'm
like okay all right let me see if he's
gonna say yes because he might he might
not and so I'll ask my husband like hey
can you give me a glass of water and
sometimes he'll look at me for like
three to five seconds and he's like I
kind of I think you can get that
yourself and I'm like okay this man
knows I'm capping he knows I'm capping
yeah yeah but it's good because if you
can fold to me you'll fold to the world
exactly right so I just I need to know
that you can stand up to me because I'm
not always going to be able to leave
myself like women I I'm gonna like
confess it yeah like we're emotional and
we're hormonal in many ways and so like
if we're because I'm also pregnant right
now and so that first trimester I'm like
I need a man to guide me because I don't
know where I'm taking myself at this
point in time but you guys were talking
about the house that actually happened
to me
um my my husband he fell in love with
the house and he's very much if you find
something he likes that's what he's
gonna get and I was worried about it
because it was a little bit it was a
little bit expensive okay uh and so I
mean he did ask for my input though but
I do give the the big life decisions I
just give it to my husband because I
don't I don't want that responsibility
on my shoulders I'm just being real but
um so we just looked at it and it was a
risk and I was like well do you think
that you know we can pull it off because
I know that my husband's also willing to
have accountability for a negative
outcome and he's like yeah well it's a
risk but I think we can swing it I think
we can pull it off and at the end of the
day we did end up uh being able to do it
so he he guessed right and nothing bad
happened and for women that are watching
even if your man fails sometimes he's a
human being like he's not going to get
100 right all the time you gotta at
least be nice about it because as wives
like we make mistakes too often often
probably more but I don't think it's
difficult you get as a wife you get a
lot of benefit of his decision so that's
why he takes the risk of doing the
bigger decision because I can't for me I
can't
if I followed everything my wife did I'd
be in debt I couldn't afford I'd be in
situations like I'd be in this like that
but it's up to me to say no I'm gonna do
what's best for us and you're and you're
just gonna have to get on board because
whatever you do like you said about the
money if he's buying a house he's not
living in there by himself like he's
living in there with his wife his
children so it's only going to benefit
them so it's like when we speak about
money in general if a man earns more
money than a woman usually the woman
gets all the benefit of that and that's
not a negative thing he actually puts
you in a better position his way of
thinking is that if I can work harder
and make more money she might not have
to work as much she might not have to
work at all she could be at home with
our kids it's all in the benefit of your
of your significant other right but if
we to flip it and women are like oh I'm
gonna earn all this money now they think
okay I don't need someone because I earn
this money so it never benefits the man
so whenever we have a conversation about
money of oh I earn a certain amount of
money as a woman and that fact is
internet attraction it doesn't because
it doesn't benefit the man the same way
a man who with that amount of money
whatever high amount you imagine that to
be would benefit his woman and his kids
so I don't even need to speak anymore I
have I have a question for the man out
of this list that we have um there's two
things that I'm surprised none of you
said I'm gonna curious if either of you
put it on
really quick if you guess there's two
I'm surprised no one's sad wait no
previous kids beauty feminine virtuous
uh friend team player knows how to keep
a house submissive loyal Cooperative
ability to learn silence knows how to
mop dust vacuum virgin ideally cultural
food and in shape there's two things I'm
surprised no one put
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible